listen no I mean it goes without saying
but you have gone from the ultimate
internet's boyfriend to a total action
star I'm like my dude's got the range
like what has that evolution been like
for you
it's been great um I feel like it's just
slow slow Little Steps here and there
um and I like it it's it's it's an it's
not like a complete 180 by any by any uh
means at all you know this is a it's a
quite a
there's so many different genres in this
and it's got disguised almost as a spy
show but there's Romance of suspense
there's there's like that home life you
know and there's also of course the CIA
the hell is this every letter is from
someone threatening to expose classified
information if we don't help them you're
the lawyer figure it out you not only
start on this but you're also an
executive producer what was that like to
wear that boss hat for the first time
you know I mean it really did
the boss hat I mean maybe he's not boss
but a leader at least because everyone's
talking about how what a great leader
you were oh wow I think what's really
cool about that more than anything is
you I was privy to information and I got
to see behind the curtain of how
something like this just made
um and just kind of try to absorb that
information as much as I possibly could
and of course you know being able to go
to your cast and say you know what's
like is there anything I can help you
with if there's anything that you need
help with or that your feeling isn't
really happening or meeting whatever you
need let me know and then maybe there's
something I can do you know and being
able to be in a position like that is
really really um I think that's that's I
don't know it's
that's where the
um
I don't know if pride is the right word
maybe there's a healthy way to use that
word and if anything that's what it is
of like okay cool like I'm in a position
where I can actually make somebody
else's life a little bit easier on this
set you should be proud it even told me
even tonight in the text chain you're
hyping up the cast and be like tonight's
the big night you know so that's amazing
you know I gotta tell you uh I loved
your reaction to your first on-screen
kiss on Gordon the other night
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a real reaction obviously you've
had so many on-screen kisses since 2009
what would you go back and tell 13 year
old Noah what advice would you give to
him man I was thinking about this
earlier tonight
um
like
it's really cool to be standing here as
a part of a project like the recruit in
this way and I was thinking about that
like 13 or like it was 11 in that first
kiss dude I mean like just keep going
yeah you know because you know you gotta
just keep going keep working hard and
see how far you get do you miss long
hair I know you got the buzz cut now I
might grow it up
although it's curly as hell now right I
don't know what happened now my hair is
all curly you can't see it now but it is
foreign